okay a Donald Trump's first trip to
Europe was a train wreck
totally disastrous speech about NATO in
Brussels that embarrassing trip to
Israel where he canceled the speech to
avoid being heckled and I know that
Israel is not part of Europe but it was
part of that same trip that he made his
comically ludicrous visit with Pope
Francis in the Vatican reminiscent of a
scene from curtir enthusiasm well Trump
is back in Europe he arrived in Poland
yesterday he will ultimately head to
Germany for the g20 meeting should be
comedy gold and this time he is not
leaving things to chance he actually
benefited today from the classic
authoritarian tactic of having
supporters and friendly crowds bust in
now Trump didn't do this himself right I
want to be pretty clear about this
Poland has a relatively right-wing
government and they came up with this
brilliant plan to give a really warm
reception to Donald Trump which is they
had each member of their current ruling
party in across the country find 50
people from their districts to get on a
bus and come in to welcome Donald Trump
and it was wacky I saw the video of it
Pat and it was like he was getting an
all-star reception which he would not
get in most countries other than maybe
Russia and people just loving it and
they called it in Poland a great
patriotic picnic this is straight out of
like North Korea Russia Venezuela which
whichever authoritarian playbook you
want to look at it's amazing that this
is the type of stuff that special
snowflake Trump is having people set up
for him around the world yeah so I know
that the Polish government set this up
but I wouldn't be surprised honestly if
Donald Trump was involved in some way
because when he announced his candidacy
for president yeah the supporter is
there were paid $50 a piece and then in
his first news conference once he became
president he build the room with aides
to cheer him on and jeer the media oh
there's no doubt that this is a tactic
that Trump has used in the past and it's
also a tactic that mirrors what was
adopted when Poland was a member of the
Soviet bloc and the Communist Party
would bus basically friendly crowds to
Warsaw to greet Dignan
Terri's from Moscow its projection
projection projection partially because
of what Pat pointed out which is that
Trump has done this he's hired paid
actors to come and cheer for him at
presidential at his presidential
announcement speech and blah blah blah
but also because he was claiming Hillary
voters were bust I believe it was from
Massachusetts to New Hampshire to vote
illegally who knows what it was at this
point but it's been Trump all along who
has called out others falsely for busing
people for political purposes and it
also matters because the guy who claims
to be against safe spaces and trigger
warnings there's no one more
thin-skinned than Donald Trump I mean
the guy just cannot handle anything oh
and of course it's all optics too it's
just the people who show up at your
event it has nothing about the greater
public at large and what they think
about you but I think Poland when it
comes to Europe would be one of the
countries that supports him relatively
so although the support of Trump
even though Poland is relatively
right-wing I believe I saw a poll
yesterday that showed support of Trump
is actually lower than it was for Obama
in order even in relatively right-wing
Poland you still had more people
supporting or approving of President
Obama than Donald Trump I may be wrong
about that don't quote me on that but if
I'm right then by all means quote yeah